.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
AMERICA IN DECLINE, THUS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THE DOW JUST CRATERED AGAIN
TODAY.
GAS PRICES, THEY ARE HEADING
BACK UP, RECESSION IS A
CERTAINTY.
THAT MEANS LAYOFFS ARE JUST IN
TIME FOR THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
BY THE WAY, YOU'RE EDGING CLOSER
TO A DIRECT WAR WITH RUSSIA.
FOR THE GUY IN CHARGE HOLD IS
THAT MEAN.
>> HE HAS TURNED IT AROUND.
LEGISLATIVE VICTORIES, LOWER
PRICES AT THE GAS PUMPS, THE
EXTREMISM OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THE TURNING POINT FOR BIDEN WAS
THE SPEECH HE GAVE A FEW WEEKS
AGO.
REALLY NEED A REFERENDUM ON THE
REPUBLICANS, SOME OF THESE
SEMIFASCIST --
IT'S STARTING TO PAY OFF.
>> SEEING PROGRESS, PERHAPS
REWARDS FOR SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION PASSED.
>> LOOK AT WHETHER BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ACCOMPLISHED.
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL,
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, THE
CHIPS AND SCIENCE ACT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE SPINNING SO
FAST THEIR HEADS ARE GOING TO
FLY RIGHT OFF.
THE ECONOMY IS IN DIRE STRAITS.
HERE IS THE TRUTH.
>> WE HAVE THE DIODE DROPPING
BELOW 30,000.
BELOW ITS JUNE LOWS.
THE DOW AND S&P ARE NOW BOTH
BELOW THEIR JUNE LOWS.
>> NASDAQ CERTAINLY ALREADY
THERE.
DOWN 22%.
ABOUT 30% YEAR-TO-DATE.
THAT WE ARE SLIPPING INTO
SOMETHING PRETTY BAD.
THE DOWEL VERY CLOSE JUST ABOUT
AT THEIR MARKET -- BEAR MARKET
TERRITORY.
>> PRETTY BLEAK PICTURE.
>> THERE IS GOOD NEWS.
>> TELL ME ABOUT DOMINO'S PIZZA.
THEY GOT AN UPGRADE.
>> ONE OF THE TOP PERFORMERS IN
THE S&P.
>> Laura: LET THEM EAT PIZZA.
MEANWHILE, GOLDMAN SACHS IS
DOWNGRADING ITS GROWTH ESTIMATES
BY 16%.
BANK OF AMERICA'S WARNING OF A
CRASH ON THE BOND MARKET SIDE.
AND GAS PRICES HAVE STOPPED
DECLINING.
ANOTHER BELLWETHER FOR THE
TUMULT WE ARE ALL FACING COME OF
THIS ONE FEDEX.
IT IS CUTTING FLIGHTS, DIFFERING
PROJECTS, CLOSING OFFICES TO
SAVE $2.7 BILLION THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
THIS IS BAD, BAD, BAD.
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
IS BUSY MAKING EXCUSES FOR THE
STEEP RAVINE WE ARE FINDING
OURSELVES IN.
>> IT'S EASY TO FORGET THAT WHEN
JOE BIDEN CAME TO OFFICE, WE
WOULD TURN ON THE TV.
PEOPLE WERE IN LINE WAITING FOR
A BOX OF FOOD.
BUSINESSES CLOSE, SCHOOLS CLOSE.
WE NEEDED AN ECONOMIC RESPONSE
THAT ADDRESS TO THAT.
>> Laura: WOULD BIDEN CAME
INTO OFFICE, THE ECONOMIC
HEADWINDS WITH THE BACKS OF ALL
OF YOU.
ALL YOU HAD TO DO AFTER YOU WERE
GIVEN THE VACCINE AND ALL THIS
CONSUMER DEMAND, RED STATES HAD
BEEN OPEN FOR MONTHS, ALL YOU
NEEDED TO DO WAS KEEP THINGS ON
AUTOPILOT.
OPEN UP WHATEVER WAS CLOSE, GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK, TURN OFF
THE SPENDING SPIGOT.
YOU HAD IT MADE IN THE SHADE.
INSTEAD BIDEN DID HIS STUPID 100
DAYS OF MASKING.
THAT EXTENDED FAR BEYOND THAT.
OF COURSE THE WHITE HOUSE ISSUED
HARMFUL VACCINE MANDATES AGAINST
FEDERAL CONTRACTORS, FEDERAL
WORKERS.
ENDED UP HAVING A PILOT
SHORTAGE, HEALTH CARE WORKER
SHORTAGE.
THEN THE FEDERAL WORKERS THAT
JUST NEVER CAME BACK.
NOW WE HAVE A FRIGHTENING
DECLINE IN OUR MILITARY
RECRUITING ALSO TIED IN PART TO
BIDEN'S VAX MANDATE.
BIDEN AND HIS TEAM OF FANATICS
HAVE CRASHED THIS ECONOMY WITH
ALL SORTS OF OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT SPILLOVER EFFECTS.
REMEMBER OVER FOUR YEARS OF
TRUMP, THE MARKET RETURNS WERE
PHENOMENAL.
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE WE FIGHTING
BIDEN.
ON INFLATION THE COMPARISON IS
STARK.
NEW ANALYSIS FROM THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION FINDS THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN HAS LOST $4,200 IN
ANNUAL INCOME SINCE RESIDENT
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
ENTIRELY WIPING OUT GAINS MADE
ON THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
LARRY SUMMERS WARNED IN THE
SPRING OF 2021 THAT THE STORM
CLOUDS WERE GATHERING.
BUT BIDEN, YELLING, RON KLAIN,
WAVE THEM ALL OFF, THEY ARE
FANATICS.
ADAMANT ABOUT PURSUING THEIR
GREEN REMAKING OF AMERICA NO
MATTER HOW MUCH DAMAGE THEY DID.
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THEY SPENT LIKE THERE WAS NO
TOMORROW, LIKE MONEY GREW ON
TREES.
THEY PROMISED THE MOON TO GET
THERE GREEN RAW DEAL PASSED
THROUGH CONGRESS, NO REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT AND ALL THEY CAN DO IS
BLAME THE GUY WHO HAS NO OTHER
CHOICE.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
>> I THINK THE FED, THEY ARE
MAKING EXACTLY THE SAME MISTAKE
ON THE OTHER SIDE THAT THEY MADE
A YEAR AGO.
>> AT THIS POINT, POWELL IS MORE
THE PROBLEM THAN THE SOLUTION.
>> Laura: THEY ARE CLEAN WITH
RATE HIKES THAT THE FED IS
OVERDOING IT.
THEY WARNED OF A GLOBAL BACKLASH
AND THEY CALLED INTEREST RATE
HIKES CRUEL.
ALSO THAT THE FEDERAL RESERVE IS
CONFUSING THE MARKET AND HURTING
THE ECONOMY.
REALITY CHECK.
IT WAS BIDEN WHO REAPPOINTED
POWELL FOR ANOTHER TERM.
THE ANGLE THOUGHT THAT POWELL
BACK IN THE SPRING OF 2021 WAS
DROPPING THE BALL ON INFLATION.
ON WHAT BASIS SHOULD
JEROME POWELL BE RE-NOMINATED AS
FED CHAIR, BY THE WAY?
HIS FAILURE TO RESPOND QUICKER
TO OBVIOUS INFLATION CONCERNS
SHOULD MEAN HE STEPPED ASIDE.
DEMOCRATS WILL NOT TAKE
OWNERSHIP OF THE SUFFERING THAT
THEY ARE INFLICTING ON ALL
AMERICANS NOW.
ALL THEY CAN DO IS SAY
JANUARY 6, JANUARY 6, AND
ABORTION OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY CAN OBSESS OVER TRUMP.
THAT'S ABOUT IT.
MORE ABORTIONS AND MORE LIZ
CHENEY ON CAPITOL HILL, IT'S NOT
GOING TO HELP COVER YOUR GROCERY
BILLS OR FILL UP YOUR CAR AND
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
RESTORE WHAT YOU'VE LOST IN YOUR
RETIREMENT ACCOUNT.
VOTERS HAVE A VERY SIMPLE CHOICE
TO MAKE IN JUST 46 DAYS.
THEY CAN VOTE FOR A COMPLETE
TURN AROUND, AWAY FROM THE PATH
OF DECLINE AND DESPAIR THAT WE
ARE NOW.
BACKWARDS COMMON SENSE,
PROSPERITY, SAFETY.
GROWTH AND OPTIMISM.
WE HAVE BEEN JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO.
THAT MEANS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
VOTE ON BOLD FOR SENATE.
IN PENNSYLVANIA, LACHMAN OZ.
ARIZONA, BLAKE MASTERS, GEORGIA,
VOTE HERSCHEL WALKER.
WASHINGTON STATE, SUPPORT
TIFFANY SMILEY, SHE IS NEWCOMER
OVER THAT TYRO WORD OLD LEFTIST
PATTY MURRAY.
IN NEVADA, ADAM LAXALT OVER
CORTEZ MAXWELL.
THAT MEANS BUT FOR EVERY
REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT AS WELL.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT RED OR BLUE OR
RIGHT OR LEFT ANYMORE.
THIS IS ABOUT RIGHT AND WRONG.
ON ALL THE ISSUES THAT MATTER,